hot breath but is your is your writing  process  are you since you've been doing it  almost 16 years is it more on stage or  do you have like a pen to paper  type of i do both i try to uh  sit and do i definitely do more on stage  now than i used to he does completely  on stage he doesn't write at all okay um  he does it all he'll have a thought  he'll think about actually kind of  ponder it and listen to sets  and then kind of go up there but he  doesn't do any pen to paper um but i'll  do  pen to paper i do a lot of writing in my  phone just if i have an idea okay  but i like pen to paper and then i have  a general idea but  you end up i end up kind of riffing on  stage a little more and have a little  more freedom to do that  so it's a little bit of both for me i  think